[Music]
okay guys so apparently
in china right now there's this whole
big old controversial story about a
couple
who took their own 22 year old daughter
to court in order to force her
to raise her two-year-old brother
what wait what yeah so they want to be
like hannah's gotta be free
they're like we don't want to raise any
more kids can't you just raise our kid
that we accidentally had
so this kid is old enough to technically
be your son even though it's not your
son but raise it like your son we want
to emancipate ourselves
yeah from you yeah well okay so you know
how china
abolished that uh one child rule so then
these parents they thought like cool we
did great with our daughter
we could afford to have another kid
let's just have another kid and then
when this other kid came in
they're like oh [ __ ] we can't afford to
to actually raise this kid we can't
raise this kid so
hey daughter you're doing great you're
you're making money you're trying to
have a career you raise your brother and
so they took her to court
and apparently according to article 29
of the marriage law of the people's
republic of china
adults whose parents have died or or are
unable
to take care of their underage children
have an obligation to take care of their
siblings
what that that kind of makes sense
so she lost the case and now she has to
raise wait but aren't they capable
but they're not they're saying they're
financially not cute that's what they're
saying so she didn't even get to make
the decision of having kids or not
the responsibility is next not next to
kim but then the highest
order of sibling that can afford it
yeah instead of that kid going straight
to
an adoption center or anything like that
special services
yeah that sucks it makes sense
in a confucius society
so this is the photo that they're using
to report this story
and the way that they're reporting it is
like i said
is that it's this huge controversial
story happening
in china but i do have to mention that
as i was trying to look into the story
some more
i didn't find more information or or
like
the sources were using the same story
like copy paste the same story so
i'm just gonna put that out there that i
don't know if this is one thousand
percent legit
because i did try to like further look
into it but
that's the story that we have at hand
and there
apparently it's just 74 million people
discussing it on china's
weibo platform yeah they have different
laws and weird [ __ ] like for example
like the bystander effect is real there
because
people were getting sued for helping oh
by the victim
whatever happened like if they fell on
the ground or something um
they were and then or like let's say
they're getting beat up and robbed or
whatever and then people come by and try
to help
and then it deters people from wanting
to help
because uh people are scared of being
sued
right for helping out the victim yeah so
they have this whole
yeah like what do you call it yeah it's
the bystander effect or whatever when
when someone's in trouble they just kind
of walk by and watch
there's a lot of weird things like that
too like like um
their laws are just different like with
the suing and all that stuff
everyone has to have like cameras on
their cars it's similar to like russia
where like
uh there's a lot of car and auto scams
where people would just
fall in front of your car or whatever
and then claim that you hit them and
yeah we've seen those videos here like
people just throw themselves to the car
one in every 10 uber drivers i i would
say back in the uber driving days
that i had yeah you drive for uber no no
no no
i used to take them because they don't
we don't take them anymore but they
would always have a dashboard camera
just because of traffic incidents or
getting people weird
one pointing to the customers and one
going out
yeah [ __ ] yeah what would happen if this
was here like if uh
the parents financially couldn't take
care of the kid it would just go to
social services or adoption probably oh
damn
even if the sibling can take care of
them it's not their
responsibility after 18 you just uh they
don't have familial ties like that
so i guess in some ways it feels like
there's gonna be less emotional damage i
guess i don't know
for the kid look at the bottom of the
bottom of the line is
making someone who is fighting because
they don't want to
have this kid yeah after they decided to
have
this kid yeah so that's the annoying
part it's like you didn't have to
i have to now go to court and say no i
don't want to have this kid
and then it's like oh congratulations
you're you have this kid now he's your
burden yeah and the whole time you're
like i don't want to have this kid your
little brother sitting there you don't
want to have me
so yeah how fun is that right how good
are you gonna treat your [ __ ] the
weight the dead weight in the room
yeah you hate him and he did nothing
wrong but i guess versus here they would
just take the kid away and just
some orphanage into the system or no not
an orphanage it's just
in foster care or like you try to find
them another family i don't think they
even have orphanages anymore
it can be i i know i have several
friends that were in the foster system
and
they love their foster parents they were
like this is the best life
so it's almost so it's like instead of
like being taken care of by your sister
who would
hate your guts to go with the family
that really wants family
like they can't have kids but they're
just like there's loads of people in the
dice because
there's also shady people in the foster
care system that are just trying to get
paychecks they don't really give a [ __ ]
about the kids
yeah there's uh my friend he lived in
his cotes at cul-de-sac and then one of
the neighbors
was like a foster house so the way that
they make money
is um it's kind of like a transitional
place
where you get foster kids
and they live until they get fully
adopted
so it's not like an orphanage but it's
just you know like it's like a group
home kind of thing
yeah they call them group homes it's
just called orphanage but yeah it sounds
exactly yeah but
when i imagine origin orphanage or
genies um
i think of like nuns running
a bunch of like a schoolyard yeah with a
bunch of kids and they don't have those
anymore
i googled it so it says while the term
orphanage is no longer
typically used in the united states
nearly every us state continues to
operate residential group homes for
children in need of safe
a safe place to live i've never seen
like a full-on
building like when i picture orphanage i
think of like this huge
place like a school with a ton of kids
but then i've seen group homes like like
the musical annie
eating slop and they're like can i have
some more please oliver twist yeah
sweetie cheeks yeah oh please also
please can i have some more peas can i
have a mommy and a daddy please like we
no we don't have that
okay yeah i see like
group homes like those just regular
residential house with a bunch of kids
living in it yeah
yeah but i don't know how it actually
works
yeah i don't know either i know like i
knew adopted kids
too where they were just full like
outright adopted as
a as a baby yeah or it's pre-planned
yeah or like from a different country or
whatever right
but yeah i never seen like a like an
institution
i want to see one now like sister i want
to
like x-man's but but it's i want to see
a bunch of kids without homes
yeah i want to go to one i want to see
damn
i just want to observe just behind the
glass he doesn't want to like be in
there
right right right yeah just want to look
at it
i want to go there and then you know say
what do you guys do here like puppet
shows and [ __ ]
like i don't know you want to invent
this place just so you can visit and ask
them what they do
i want to know if it still exists like
in america because i know it
exists outside it doesn't exist in
america why like there's got to be a
reason why
it doesn't exist because there's
psychological damage to the kids
there's no stable yeah there's there's
it might be too many people that
well so it's a failed experiment i'm
assuming
if it was good it'd be around i feel
like if my parents weren't in the
picture it would have been impossible to
raise that many kids
like like i have three siblings yeah
like there's no [ __ ] way i could have
pulled that off
because you're the oldest i'm the second
oldest so it would have been me and my
sister or whatever but man
i don't know that's just worth so much
was there a lot of responsibility on you
to like do stuff like
yeah you know go cook the beans while i
change this diaper not really i mean
you like to think that there was because
me and my sister we definitely like
helped
with my brothers and [ __ ] but it wasn't
like crazy like we're not driving them
around and [ __ ] all the stuff that's
real work that you don't even register
as real work at the time
yeah impossible that's crazy i do
remember like
a lot of the kids i went to school with
like in high school if they were the
oldest
they were literally like the parents
that's my sister with us yeah she was a
mom for sure
um this one girl she was like 14
15 and she would take her little brother
on the paper route
so she's driving the family van and i'm
like she doesn't have a license
it's my [ __ ] classmate what the [ __ ]
the paper rub that's like
they're delivering papers like 4am i
don't know if it's that early but yeah i
remember
seeing her drive are you thinking
newspaper but there's also like the
the coupons and whatever
local business ads oh she was riding a
uh like a van
and i was like crap what the [ __ ] yeah
yeah
yeah i hope like i don't know how they
do stuff in china
but i i hope that the parents are also
at least sentenced
to help the daughter raise so if they
can't
contribute financially they should be
punished for
for having a baby irresponsibly yeah
yeah that's true
because it's almost like they're just
gambling right like they're like oh i
guess they changed a lot so we're gonna
have a second kid oh [ __ ] we don't have
enough money for a second kid yeah
they're being reckless yeah that's why i
was so interested in this story and i
wanted to find out more too like are the
parents gonna have any sort of
like punishment at all and i couldn't
find out so
how are they gonna punish them they're
already poor or like to to help out
like physically like make them get a job
maybe they figured out that they can't
get them like they like they tried
earning and then they're like
not even like earning money but just
like changing diapers and like
yeah right yeah being there babysitting
like that kind of stuff
i mean they could walk right if they
could walk or not even if they can go
from point a to point b
take them out of [ __ ] two years or three
years ago-ish
yeah to make this kid so what's gonna
happen if they pop out another one
that's what i'm like and they're like oh
we thought we could this time
yeah we [ __ ] up again but we [ __ ] up
again we made the two-year-old raise
that one
[ __ ] they take the tear to court yeah
he wears a little suit and represents
himself
yeah i like that [ __ ] they used to pop
out just mad kids so they can all take
care of the farm
and then like work each other out
[Music]
[Music]
you